My name is Vicki. My field of work is in
IT.
Thank you for this opportunity to ask
the question and may Allah bless you Dr.
Zak for all the dawa you've done and all
and also mayo
give you the highest jana for
inspiring Muslims around the world.
>> Amen. uh regarding the Palestine uh
where our brothers and sisters in
humanity and faith being massacred by
this uh Zionist terrorist. We see on the
media uh there is like uh we see this
regime's prime minister, the soldiers,
the politicians and even the citizens
they bring up this term Amalcch or
Amalikites when they uh mention our
brothers Palestinians, right? My
question is has God according to your
knowledge in comparative religion and
scriptures has God the most loving the
creator the most compassionate the most
merciful has he ever commanded his
believers to uh kill non-combatants such
as uh little babies, children, women
like happens in Palestine like basically
destroy everything even buildings like
um hospitals every house and religious
building like mosque. Thank you.
>> The question has God told the people to
kill children, babies, destroy
hospitals. Nowhere it is mentioned in
the Bible or the Jewish scriptures.
This is their
nowhere it is mentioned that it should
kill the babies or or destroy the
hospitals or destroy the schools. This
is because they want the land. It is
more for you know it is uh the
greediness.
If if you're asking me the question and
talking how will you understand?
>> You can't do both things. Correct.
>> If you ask me a question you shouldn't
talk to him.
>> Oh I said
>> right or wrong.
>> I said about Amalcch. Amalikat. What
about them?
>> Who?
>> Amal. Amalat. Amalik. Amal.
>> What is Amalik?
>> Oh yeah. Amalikites.
>> The Amalch. The people of Amal in the
Bible. Right.
That's what you says.
>> Yes.
>> That we have a right. This is his false
reading. This is not correct. This is
his understanding. He's picking up some
verses of the B of of Jewish scriptures
and manipulating it, justifying his
action, which is totally wrong. And many
Jews have taken out protest that he's
not a Jewish, he's not a practicing Jew.
There are many Jewish people in America
in UK are protesting against
that what he's saying is wrong. He's
justifying
by picking up things from the Jewish
scriptures which doesn't say say so at
all. It's totally fabrication. Hope that
answers the question.